so you're behind the scenes
i want to know because pusha t is one of
my favorite rappers ever
pusha t has been he was poking and
prodding at lil wayne
for years ever since mr me too which is
for a long time that's prior to you
being with young money that should the
pusha t and
young money or wayne [ __ ] that should go
back way before me
like i just right i just probably only
entertained it because i was young money
at the time
yeah because like you know i'm saying it
it took wayne i want to say it was maybe
three or four years ago we finally said
push his name on a record
or he's it was i don't remember what he
said he's finally acknowledged pusha t
officially
yeah and i was like wow but like
was that like was that something that
like
like like was a known issue in the crew
like man this [ __ ]
these guys over here man they're [ __ ]
disrespectful nah you know why because
wayne being his own little world
so wayne don't really listen like he
don't really be knowing what'd be going
on it'd be like me or gutter or like
i gotta tell him to show him something
yeah a little twist would always come in
and show him some [ __ ] on the laptop or
twitter or instagram here big bro look
at this huh so he would be so far into
his music
he wouldn't really know about like the
darts
but when he find out about it it'll be
like a word i'll pull that [ __ ] up let
me see that [ __ ]
and then everybody like all the
assistants and managers will be like oh
god mills why did you get them started
i remember we was in the studio
and yay came to play uh him
uh over the zaytoven production
i don't know if i even wanted to know
finish the story
he didn't feel that [ __ ]
uh the damn what was the bar in there
man
i just remembered baby money you got
baby money that ain't my late something
my lady money that's baby money you got
like it was some [ __ ] like that wayne
walked out the room
while kanye song's still playing like
just went to go get like a
cup of water and [ __ ] like yeah that
and i remember like two days later
he did a song was it drake jada kissing
wayne was that carter three
kidnap your [ __ ] kidnap your [ __ ] see
how much you love your lady money
that was carter three no i think that
was that was carter i think it was
drake it might have been it might have
been called a four caught carter ford
was drake
jadakiss and wayne because watch the
throne came out in 2011. it was four
four apartment it was four i remember i
don't remember much from that album it
wasn't good
this is when i liked carter four it just
wasn't caught at three well yeah
it just wasn't caught at three carter
four was fired up it was all right uh
i remember he was like yo y'all think
that's too much
everybody was like no i think you should
take that ball out man i don't think you
should really say that
man [ __ ] that [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
everybody got mad at me
as soon as he's like you know what i was
like yo do you feel
like right he was talking about you
not necessarily i was like bro this is
words it ain't like you it ain't like
if he was talking about you he was that
jay who said that or yeah it was jewish
it was jay so at this point [ __ ] you
you
you you just sold a million records of
course first week came home and you
about to do it again
this is you you right now if you feel
this is just a battle rapper in me at
this time but this is how much i [ __ ]
with wayne this is
this is what wayne looks at me for you
know what i'm saying
i'm like do you feel like it was a shock
i'm like no cersei do you feel there was
a shot because if you didn't feel it was
a shot you wouldn't have thought of the
bar you thought of
so you asking us for validation to go in
there
to go say what you feel now
you know what you're right he went in
there turn me up
lighter everybody looking at me
yeah cause i do feel like why would you
tell him to do that there was like this
period of time where
and i'm like why not though i'm like at
the end of the day it's words it's just
sport
it's rap it's not like he said i'm gonna
kill you
you felt he said something and you
wanted to say something back dude
do you feel like that there was some
contention growing between hove and
wayne
i feel like there's some contention
growing between hove and anybody else
that gets hot
to the point where they're on his radar
yeah because i remember i remember that
[ __ ] go back to nas
well there was the rumors that that
wayne was going to leave cash money and
then
signed with rock rockefeller i remember
that i remember that being a thing a few
different times
and then and then it seemed like even
back before i was with young money i
think wayne and jay
had some business history i think jay
was going to sign him or
he was going to give him like a
situation or something that go back wait
it just seemed like and then it said
what happened jay said in an interview
that he called baby
to let him know that they were talking
maybe the next day his lawyer
but then there was like after the carter
three
it felt like there was like this almost
like an unspoken like
like like energy between the two where
it was like wayne was the only guy who
was like challenging hope is that dude
yeah and i felt like that i feel like it
was definitely like was that talked
about
like openly or was it more just like oh
you mean amongst us like
the crew nah we always looked at even
wayne wayne look at jay like jay
he's a ghost but wayne his favorite
like person ever is like
prince kobe bryant like if anybody knows
wayne they will tell you mills no wayne
off that
it's prince and kobe bryant michael
jackson is cool but to wayne
michael jackson isn't prince you know
what i'm saying
jordan jordan is cool too but to wayne
yeah kobe could have won seven you know
what i'm saying so it's like his media
his mentality is i love mike but i'm
coming at him
and i think that's what it always was
with jay even if you go back to i'm the
best rapper alive
since the best rapper retired and then
once jay-z wasn't retiring no more he
never stopped calling himself the best
rapper alive though he just
kept calling himself he's like oh you
back i thought it was my turn i thought
you was retiring
well i'm still i'm still that [ __ ] here
so if you that [ __ ] and i'm
i'm the best though i know you might be
the greatest but i'm the best like right
now i'm the best
and i think wayne just carried that [ __ ]
for so long he carried that [ __ ] for so
long
it's you heard it when you you when you
heard him about to come on a song
you just felt that energy like he just
feel he about to come on he used to tell
us that
right he used to play beats and look at
me and drake and nikki and tiger gutter
whoever was on the song
oh i'm just letting y'all boys know like
i'm gonna kill all y'all [ __ ] on this
song right now
and turn around and just turn this [ __ ]
all the way back up and light his blood
that's